we can see how transmedia would work for
million-dollar sort of ad campaign but
for a low-budget film for somebody
that's an independent filmmaker may be
working with a six-figure budget how can
they incorporate transmedia
it seems like it's almost out of the
picture for them and you would think I
mean this is this I think this is one of
the biggest misconceptions of transmedia
is that we you know and part of the it's
it's it's my fault because I talk about
large projects Star Wars you know Harry
Potter your things like this we look
toward the all the Marvel stuff that's
going on now the way they design their
projects is tremendous for the audience
experience and the only reason that they
do that the only reason that these
projects are rolling out the way they
are rolling out is because the market
has an appetite for it so so they're
proving the fact that the audience wants
that type of a project something that
that is an ever go dark experience so
after the movie I still should be able
to go home Andale - experience more
stories somewhere else after the you
know between episodes of the TV show I
should be able to engage online with
some sort of added content but this is
what the market was so we can establish
that but again how how - how does an
indie filmmaker how to do that if they
don't have you know a billion dollars at
their disposal in my perspective it's
all about how do we use the principles
of George Lucas how do we use the
principles of Marvel how do we use the
principles of Harry Potter and apply
them - to our project our smaller
project or independent project that's
what fascinates me I think most about
about this because the the law of
gravity does it say the law lifts the
law lift over overcomes the law of
gravity in order to make an airplane fly
you look at a 777 that picks up off the
off the ground and flies into the sky
you you don't say well I have to have a
777 in order to fly you know yeah you
could have a smaller
and if you understand the law lift and
the law gravity and how those work
together if you just understand those
principles your tiny little plane can
fly just as much as the the big 777 you
may have to gas up more times you may
not may not be able to go as far but you
can still get in the air and so so
that's the way I look at it I look at
you know star wars of the 777 but if
this star wars is proving to us what the
law lifts of what the law of gravity can
do let's take those laws and apply them
to our own project because I think is
actually more necessary for an
independent project to be able to or an
independent producer and independent
screenwriter to be able to understand
the multi-platform world in a transmedia
world and what I call a super story
model if we're because they don't have
the P&A budgets that's what it really
breaks down to the three hundred
thousand dollar picture the hundred
thousand dollar picture they're not
gonna have the thirty five million
dollar P&A budget they're not gonna have
the seventy million dollars a PNA to be
able to let everybody know who they are
what their project is and why they
should support it so they have to
approach the marketplace differently
again the the if the lemonade stand
analogy if there's a thousand other
lemonade stands not only a thousand
other eliminates ants but a thousand
other lemonade enterprises that are much
bigger and more expensive and they have
better lemons and more money to spend
you have to figure out a different way
because you don't have the same you know
same resources and so if you look at how
you advertise you know it's to get one
commercial on one time for 30 seconds on
Fox in primetime $350,000 just for the
not just the production budget of the of
the commercial just for the 30-second
hole to display one one commercial one
time so usually independent filmmakers
don't have that to spend or if they do
what I say
what would happen if you did one less
commercial what would happen if you took
that through new $50,000 and you would
spend it on something that that could
actually give your fans or people that
that support your project more content
and how do we differentiate ourselves in
the market
how do we spend the money wiser and so
you know for me I look at something like
moonlight
you know before moonlight won an Oscar
it it very few people saw it and
moonlights a great film but if you look
at the box-office before it won the
Oscar in the box office after won an
Oscar it's very different it was only
only a few theaters made a few thousand
undred thought you know $100,000 or so
then after when the Oscar got the wide
release but you can't as an independent
producer you can't build a business plan
around winning an Oscar all I've got to
do is win an Oscar then we're good so
you gotta approach the marketplace
differently and so so for me it I will
take I want to look at an independent
project and say okay this in the print
project how can I begin to seed interest
and awareness and develop pre awareness
before my movie comes out so the two
years that it takes to even produce a
film in a release of film you could be
already building pre awareness for it
through things like self publishing a
novel you can release interesting
digital content you can give all your
characters in your in your script
Twitter accounts and as if they were
real people and go ahead and start
seeding storylines and create
interaction between the months before
the film that is ever released you can
you can go after different markets and
create music content that may give you
access to a different target market than
the main target market of your movie and
none of that you can do some of these
things that can actually start
generating revenue well ahead of the
release of the film so so for me the
that is a much better spin than a single
commercial that you would spend on the
back end and that gives that gives your
fan base now more content to dig into
and gives you a separation and
marketplace from all the other
independent films that are being
released so so you know if you look at
if you look at if you look at programs
like AMC independent where the you know
you can go directly to the exhibitor
with bypassing the distributor which is
a great program the way they choose
which which projects to put into the
AMC Indy program is how how are you
going to build awareness for your
campaign or for your film how are you
going to let people know that you that
you're there because you're not going to
have the distributor paying for the PA
so so now you have to have that
mechanism to build pre awareness but
what's cool is after you that's
architectures out there any fans that go
into the film that haven't seen all the
stuff that you've done even to build
pretty awareness they now can go back
flow backwards and access it and now
it's extended content for them so now
after I see the moonlight movie I can go
read the moonlight novel that's a
continuation of it I can then go dig
into the into the comic books they see
new storylines there's a you could use a
book of poetry that gives you insight
into it a whole different character lots
of stuff that you can do understanding
the principles of the big guy but be
able to apply it to your independent
project in a way that gives you that
separation and advantage in the
marketplace
that's excellent let me just make sure I
understand it because I still have
trouble you know wrapping my mind around
the concept of transmedia
so it's like building bridges if we're
using this architectural sort of analogy
it's building bridges it's not repeating
the same story over and over again okay
exactly yeah we you know for me I never
want to tell the same story twice that
that's what my goal is I go into a
transmedia project I never want to tell
the same story twice because the the
thing that fans love the most the most
more than anything is new story and you
know I just recently binge doll six
seasons of Game of Thrones and after six
seasons in a in a month all I wanted was
more story and I was searching for more
story and searching for more story I
thought about going and reading the
books but I knew the books would pretty
much tell me the same story and so I
wanted new stuff that's what I wanted
most of all and so that's what that's
what famous one you know when I was it
when I was a kid my mom bought me I was
a Star Wars fan and my mom bought me the
novelization of the original trilogy
which was great in the in you know in
the in the early 90s there wasn't a lot
of stuff out there I was a good I was a
heavy reader so she got me the book I
read it it was good
it was the same story in both places and
so it was okay but in the Empire Strikes
Back there's a scene in The Empire
Strikes Back that where Darth Vader is
talking to a group of bounty hunters and
he tells them all to go out and catch
Han Solo Boba Fett is the only one who
does and you never see all those other
bounty hunters again one day my mom
bought me a different book called the
tales of the bounty hunters which was
the short story anthology following all
those other bounty hunters and their
adventure trying to catch Han Solo and
ultimately how they failed for me when I
read that as a kid it was revelatory
because it was new Star Wars stuff like
it wasn't the same stuff it was new Star
Wars stuff which was awesome I like
completely devoured that book in a
couple days because it was new and and
for the filmmakers it was a great way
one to generate new revenue two to
continually engage an audience in new
stuff without having to shoot another
movie so it for filmmakers if the
filmmakers only think the way to tell
stories is through movies then they
won't tell that many stories because
it's very as you know it's very
expensive and difficult to be able to
shoot movies all the time and so even if
you spend the rest of your life making
movies and you never stop there's gonna
be two year gaps you know it means gonna
be when you go into development
pre-production production
post-production distribution it's a
two-year cycle to be able to get a movie
out into the market and so if all you
did is make movies there's gonna be
two-year gaps where you're not engaging
fanbase so now in in this oversaturated
world of entertainment not engaging your
fans for two years two years as a
dangerous thing and so and so now you
have to figure out different ways to
engage them well how do I do it if I
can't make movies well you do you use
other things just as much and so as
you're making your movies let's be
feeding our fans new content through all
the things that we have owned at our
disposal social media content I'm not
talking about advertising through social
media I'm saying you know how do we
deliver content through social media
that extends the story in a valuable
how do I don't use a digital content how
do I use comic books self-published
novels music art you know fine art you
can do sculptures you can do poetry you
can do anything that can tell a story
stage plays TV whatever you want all the
options are out there that one can give
your audience more engagement and more
story which they love more than more
than anything else and two it gives your
investors more of an opportunity to
capture revenue and so one of the
biggest obstacles for for an independent
artist is how do you find investment
money how's the independent investor
look at your movie and find that it's a
good business model and and what we've
seen now is the investment that the
pools of investment money is drying up
rather quickly it's very difficult to be
able to go out and get them the amount
of money that we need to create these
films because the business model doesn't
make a lot of sense anymore there's been
too much disruption in the marketplace
it creates it costs too much to
advertise for a film
I mean Steven Soderbergh was just he
just had a an interview where he said
just to be a blip on the radar now you
have to have 35 billion dollars of
domestic PA 35 million dollars of
international PA just to be a blip on
the radar to let people know you there
because there's so much competitions too
many lemonade stands in the neighborhood
and which means that's 70 million
dollars of PA to recoup to recoup your
PA it's 50 cents on a dollar so all of a
sudden to recoup that 70 million dollars
a PA you have to make 140 million
dollars
add in let's say let's say you have a
million dollar production budget then
it's 141 million dollar breakeven on a 1
million dollar picture so imagine
yourself as a businessman I go to I go
to you and say I say Karen will you
invest in my script for a million
dollars we can make this amazing film
together and all we have to do is make a
hundred and forty-one million and you
get all your money back that doesn't
make a lot of sense right and so now
people say well well well I won't do any
PNA thing I'll just you know don't go
won't go
distributor and just self you know self
distributed whatever that now if you
don't have if you don't have another
plan of how to build awareness for your
project and engage in audience it that's
maybe even more dangerous than the first
rounds or you may you may say well I'll
cut back on the PA or off you know and
then it's just a game of how far can I
cut back and still be able to survive so
for me if we can figure out a different
way forward to say to an event to go to
an investor and say here is how we're
going to give you a different business
model here's how we're going to give you
an opportunity to recoup faster and to
coop more and recruit over a longer
period of time and so now instead of
just one revenue stream that I can
generate that you can recoup which is
the movie it's gonna be the main one now
there's gonna be four or five additional
ways that you can recoup and the only
that as we wait our two years before you
start recouping from the movie you'll be
recouping in these other two ways that
are gonna hit the marketplace a lot
earlier so you'll be recouping your your
investment well before the movie even
hits the market which is great and
instead of the two to five year window
that you'll have to recoup the bulk of
your investment from the film now we can
build it to where there's a 15 year
window because after the movie gets out
and it has this two-year window to
generate the revenue then we're gonna
release this and then we're gonna
release this and that's going to bridge
the gap but up until the time you maybe
want to release a different film and and
you're gonna be a play a part of all
that
so here's product diversification we
have a product line diversification we
have multiple streams of revenue we're
hitting not just one or two markets now
we're going to hit seven markets for a
longer period of time when you start to
position yourselves like that now it
becomes a better business decision for
the investor which is better for the
independent producer because somebody
has to pay for your movie because then a
lot of people say to me well I'll just
do Kickstarter Kickstarter's the savior
of the independent of the independent
film you know ninety percent of films
that are on Kickstarter don't get funded
at all get zero
and it's so sad and and and and it's
just there's that much stuff out there
the 10% that do get funded get funded
and on an average of twelve thousand
dollars and to make a to make a career
as a independent filmmaker we can't we
have to we have our vision has to be
greater than twelve thousand dollar
movies listen if you get twelve thousand
dollars to make a movie god bless you
that's awesome I'm not saying I'm not I
don't want to diminish that
accomplishment but it's but ultimately
we don't want to have to be baristas as
we as we make movies we don't want to
have to have our day job and shoot on
the weekends as you do the grind that's
awesome that's what you should do but we
need a bigger vision and a better
business model to be able to have a new
way forward you know I like to say at
some point at some point well the
lightbulb wasn't invented by the
continuous improvement of the candle at
some point somebody had to say okay the
candles great god bless the candle
candles awesome but we now need to kind
of build a different model to be able to
get a bigger results and so now we've
seen independent films being diminished
in the marketplace and and the answer to
that isn't just writing it better or
shooting it better of course you need to
write it well and shoot it well but we
also need to build a different
architecture around it so it can be
sustainable and have an advantage in the
marketplace especially how we how we
communicate it to it to a an investor I
just had a filmmaker go to me for a he
had he wanted to raise $10,000 for a
short film it's all he wanted to do he
said do you think there's nothing
transmedia potential here I looked at it
and we we kind of worked together for
about a day and I kind of added a few
tricks to it and kind of built out the
IP and he went talked to this investor
who he was going for a $10,000
investment he walked away with a two
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
investment because all of a sudden it
the whole thing made more sense business
sense
right and so and so that now he was so
happy as independent filmmaker saying
now I can actually
shoot my short shoot these other things
I actually can go into pre-production
on my feature my investor can be being
paid back based on these other two
things and now has an equity stake in
the feature film as we move forward
etc etc and he was super excited and all
he's all we did is he's using the
principles of Star Wars the principles
of Harry Potter the principles of the of
Marvel and building that in to his
independent film business plan that
separates him in the marketplace
you